anyway hello to people if you're just
joining I just started I'm late joining
this David Pakman arena it's being
organized by David Pakman himself and
it's attracting wait this doesn't look
right let me refresh there we go so
there's there's close to 600 players
david has a massive following on on
YouTube and I think he's multi streaming
on Twitch YouTube Facebook there's also
a popular streamer destiny who's playing
in this so I'm playing yep clock
there's no berserk king I'll try and be
competitive and yeah the determent
started I think with an hour and 10
minutes
so yeah just just over 15 minutes late
and I play aggressive I'll play quickly
I'll try and try and eat the little
blu-ray players quickly why do I look
green do I look green all the green
should be like keyed out because of the
chroma key also welcome back Finny
welcome back to everyone else thanks
Akash for the host so we have some
technical variation the structure is not
so pretty for black my idea is like b3
Bishop b2 and an attack on the kingside
oh you're about to sleep but I'm more
important than self-care well yeah still
take care of yourself maybe you can
still drift off to sleep while I
watching this play d3 defend the pawn
yeah so you can use a join command light
box is sharing the link in the chat see
for free pawn
Bishop I like free stuff hey Eric man
raising hand man raising hand oh hey man
what's up
harsh thanks for subbing welcome back
thanks man
okay let's go in for the kill
going after f7 what's very pleasant my
age six was probably expected and maybe
Queen f3 attacking the rook what else to
do maybe Bishop e3 my box position is uh
is about to crumble or in the process of
crumbling interesting hmm don't play
this I'm happy to like open that file
and then get the rook involved I'm
predicting the game's gonna end after
this this and then rock f7 meet it's
just a prophecy are you Rosen yes
I'm Rosen thanks TW for the bits so when
you have the chat have the child open on
both sides hey it's a panda individual
Eric hello thanks for solving for five
months
opponents very perplexed here not an
easy position for black all the pieces
are on the back rink Knights are
involved mmm
let's do this move thanks for providing
such insight oh thank you so I'm
fighting meat if Queen takes Knight then
I made on f7 g6 good move actually g6 is
a really good move I kind of just
soon that this would go well for me but
it's still good for me
I'm just not meeting immediately my
nights gonna fall
we'll have elaborate d1 coming
so there's still things I want to do
involving taking on c5 now there's ideas
of rook e8 maybe a combination of those
oh but they're taking on c5 right away
black takes back of check so a five
opens up the bishop and then if here I
win the knight of here then I check in
win the Knights and its leading to mates
regardless
okay that was the first game 49 minutes
left and some change
I'm in 230 second place so it's gonna
take some work first place has 16 points
oh it's piano chess wait you know just
the same one there's a twitch streamer
maybe it's slightly different though
name rings a bell
okay playing cat post I have to keep
reminding myself there's no buzzer King
but I'll play a Smith Bora
David Pakman is a political commentator
he was on Joe Rogan very recently
actually on Joe Rogan twice maybe about
six months ago as well and he's a avid
chess player to juice thanks for subbing
actually I had this position a few days
ago this is not good for black I Bigley
remember like Brian asking me why I
didn't play Queen a4 after d5 here 95
what does this move I can take the night
and then invade oh okay oh Lord I just
win a queen mmm this is very close to me
well it's das although with bits thanks
so much das Auto and it's checkmate
thanks opponents okay top hundred let's
go Sheila height 25 emails shared I
wonder maybe twitch is doing some kind
of a email thing promotion I appreciate
that
alright so I'm gonna continue playing
aggressively this is a Kings gambit bulk
your counter gambit this move is losing
to Queen each for this is exactly what I
like to see opponents falling for or
some nice opening traps
and the Queen should not get trapped if
not a three I have the very least I have
Bishop each three now the bishop on
earth ones pinned and pressured so at
any time I can take in and trade Queens
a bishop defends this pawn - let's do
this
I'm just trying to play aggressively so
the queen is now overworked so the idea
is to take take and then take and then
fork everything the GMT JMT thanks for
the prime sub for five months why is the
tournament named after David Pakman
because David's organizing this and
streaming it shout out to I think his
name is just David Pakman in twitch
destiny is also streaming it so shout
out to destiny who's like a very large
swing around twitch IG one setting up
for the next game like g1 is actually
very logical so it cuts the pinned or X
trucks a queen from hitting the bishop
King takes good move so the plan the
plans together rook to f8 you're pulling
me I've had this move oh thanks Brian
for the good luck this
oh the shallow destiny didn't work
because the cooldown maybe that works so
I could Castle defending my king and
attacking lights King very ironic move
I'll play this move defending both bonds
and threatening the fork very
multi-purpose then I'll probably castle
and threatened some discovery always
castle with check except when you can
play a move like this
Oh h2 is also hanging once h2 hangs and
g3 hangs everything following Oh where's
it mates let's take a thing yeah this
will probably come down to like how
quickly I can win positions like this
place
oh wait a minute let's sum I'm not
seeing the me oh I can win a queen
though that's good enough
rookies attacked Hey it's dawn silver
with 301 bits thanks so much
okay so some very quick wins a
tournament points on a streak leader has
16 oh hi ray player 2 1 FM also tied Oh
a lot of players with 16 so it's a six
way tie for first I'm halfway there
why have I been avoiding London because
e4 is also fun have to show some love to
the best by test even though London is
also best all right so I'm gonna try and
play aggressively I'll probably end up
castling queenside and then like pawns
form interesting play 5 and I'll go for
like g5g for hey Eric hey
Apogee chess thanks for subbing becoming
a twitch baby 9 months
thanks so much yeah let's attack
objectively this is probably not like a
great strategy oh that's actually a good
move ooh yeah that's probably why this
isn't a great strategy for me
I'm getting two pawns I'm just trying to
go for the kill
eventually so well you against a good
player I'd probably like get punished
but here I'm being rewarded so like
sometimes when you want to win quickly
in chess you have to play in a slightly
dubious or risky fashion but it paid off
18th place
let's go 12 points Oh a few people have
20 now oh hello to pirata the chief from
Portugal I was in Portugal in Portugal
like a year and a half ago very nice
country is mainly in Lisbon ah maybe
it's gonna play a London but then I
forgot let's play one of these things oh
you wanted Jerome I want to not Vincent
if here I'll play Knight c3 enactments
and gambits up one's thinking here a lot
of people start thinking in that
position what's the move here it's this
and then night here and then rookie 1
and threatening each three is there
delay on the audio cells lie Sameer
maybe you've refresh hopefully there's
no big delay you might have to refresh
sometimes weird things happen for
inexplicable region reasons
d6 is a good move called take and then
take care probably don't need to kick
the night yeh 3 probably only helps
black like pre centralized indict even
te 5 so sequel material oh but it's a
pleasant position because I have nice
development hmm that's a slightly
annoying move
we can play this this pawn is like box
biggest weakness some ideas of 95 but I
am currently attacking the pawn twice Oh
green hair oh yeah yeah I was trying to
fix a green screen thing so there's a
small green outline I guess I hope it's
not too distracting earlier my my
forehead was kind of transparent so I
think that was even more distracting
probably just have to fix the lighting
or something I could take the pawn take
the pawn and then Bishop f4 coming ooh
tricky move good move though probably
you should not have allowed that so I
can take the knight I think I'll take
the knight and then develop with tempo
so that was a good trait to relax e24 d6
so now it's completely symmetrical
symmetrical pawn structure I have a bit
of initiative so there's some like
temporary advantage attack and defend
probably rook c1 trying to develop with
tempo eg sudden welcome back I play this
Bishop e5 green hair he hahahaha
alright let's play this move I don't
want to trade Queens want to keep things
complicated keep some attacking chances
alive and this Bishop is really awkward
it's in some committed relationship with
the Queen I'll play this move if there
should be four I think I've three traps
a bishop ooh make be for a while so d3
is
a box idea that's nifty move I have
tried g4 actually don't know here hmm
well I could play this move if 93 I take
it and then pin and maybe win
and it's getting complicated this could
just lead to a very big train its
Lockleys precisely well
not expecting that it shouldn't change
much
yeah there there is a move for black to
not lose material and we'll see if I can
find it
if flock doesn't find it then I'm just
winning material yeah so oh oh that made
me also works because my thing hangs oh
but maybe okay let's do this and then
rook to d1 rook to you and I'm gonna
look t2
I'm trying to pin the knight in two
directions and not attack the knight
three times all right that was nice yeah
black so instead of 93 buck should've
played Bishop d3 hey sixteen points
ooh leader has 24 points I'm catching up
to do playing Oh social
something-something I'll play d4 just
for Brian playing a London
it's a flame I mean repertoire okay here
we might my transpose into okay Joe Bava
London a Barry attack Neal how's it
going
you got Jess welcome back thanks for the
bits I starting this um a few weeks ago
to remember some kind of preparation I
think it's 95 and some Queen d2 there's
some cool trap oh yeah
so Queen 85 is like the most natural
move and then Queen d2 like you seven
also playable Oh a 97 there's some crazy
lines there's also some quiet lines I
think c6 is a move there are some lines
with takes takes Queen e8 night b5 I'm
also wondering if I can throw in this
move actually don't see the reason why
not so I want a pawn and the bishop is
actually really well placed here the
defense of knight in events like Queen
a5 and night here
also if the night ever moves I'm happy
to trade and the Queen can also come in
and just reinforce everything Queen b6
is a probably a decent move a situation
okay so actually join Nita actually
probably defend so I want to play Queen
d4 because a plan to to create the
battery to try and trade queens now I
joined the tournaments use the joint
command and then click bullying there's
a lot of people in this tournament it's
competitive Queen d4
mmm [ __ ] will develop somewhere at some
points maybe should t3 I mean this is
just very nice hunter control the Queen
on d4 it's usually like not so great to
put a queen like in a center square but
here it's really hard for black to
attack Bishop is always shielding the
Queen from discoveries and this Bishop
cutter is c4 so there's no work c4 in
the meantime I probably want to castle
unpin the Knights eventually pressure
the pawn maybe before some day [ __ ] a6
oh yeah so if it takes takes and the
pawn will cover c4 there's also the
possibility of maybe if I have the
chance to take and then take on d5 it
could be risky with her t8 ideas
oh there's also d4 might be a threat
maybe it was a possibility actually
should see four interesting so I can't
play b3
I'll just improve a rook takes a - I
have this move
complex position I could actually play
be three things defended there's also
before entirely sure
who's f3 let's put f3 restricting the
night I honestly wasn't sure what else
to do
I'd rather my opponent be thinking than
me making each morning just a lot of
like just safe improving those trying to
drain my phone's time is this a free
pawn smells like a free pawn Oilers
thanks for subbing for 7 months
appreciate that smooth back lock wanted
to target this thing I want to target
this these things you at some point like
rook T to double up before g3 also to me
logical
getting a very big time advantage okay
so I'll take um g3 is okay lights coming
to have five I'm up to pawns here I just
have to be careful of things
so the king should probably be on f2 a
lot considering sacking maybe I don't
think it works
mmm it's interesting move so if I take I
can't take oh that's probably a good
move
you need this nifty response we need you
six five ninety four Queen c7 ooh good
move
I'm actually in a little bit of trouble
here yeah that was really about to allow
I'm wondering if I can get away with
taking what's really risky play this
probably ninety-two not the move I
wanted to play
so I'm down the exchange but I'm still
trying to fight good move
this is really bad to allow you very
well lose this
before before probably doesn't work I'm
looking for a way to defend the pawn
like defend doesn't quite work though
it's unfortunate
trying ooh there goes another pawn
that's a good move too so I have to have
hoped for like some weird random flag or
some random fork
please please oh no doesn't even work
[Music]
oh okay I win the pawn pawns nervous
this is gonna be oh just a long game
though the Knights are tricky never
resigned when you have a knight
oh wait I just dropped tonight's ha time
to resign ah I figure out the king would
unleash the discovery that was rough
yeah there goes my hope of uh of winning
I'll still try and uh and and have a
decent finish that's a bummer though I
had a great position great time
advantage the opponent was very
resourceful especially with this pawn
break not a five idea okay stop for
gambit time this is an opening I play
when I know Stafford gambit this is
still what I play when i I want to try
and win quickly there's something a bit
more ambitious here
Hey long time no see long time no see
I'll Homer welcome back it's been so
long but I still remember how to
pronounce your name Nile as in file
let's play push a d7 so I provoked h3
which in some cases can be useful
because g4 will be more of a break yeah
let's play g4 here it's all about the
file action like once the G file opens
and I'll have a lot of possibilities
what T am i drinking I'm drinking the
tea of coconut also known as coconut
water
I should play three Bishop b4 oh I can
look into that I play so when one of the
reasons to play for Knights actually a
few reasons one is center for check
another reason is reverse Halloween
gambit is sometimes a possibility Knight
d5 so I think I'm gonna just ignore the
center go for some just immediate attack
though the king is a little bit unhappy
aligned with the bishop so maybe King ah
fates could be a decent square for the
King black wants to win my my pawn
wondering if it makes sense to take the
knight
it broke g6 - I think I'll take first
because the knight was on pinned and
then something like rook g6
or maybe I can sack the pawn
the reason to sack the pawn would have
been to open the file that would have
been hard together work to to h8 can
also consider this idea so this Bishop
this is one of the I guess downsides of
doing this is white is a bishop really
can't move which is nice
okay now 303 would be a triple four if
Queen III it would be discovery for
please c6 so I want to chase away the
night to access maybe the square may be
the square as well maybe the square
I'm not scared of the fossil thanks for
subbing Cobalts do I want to allow the
trade I don't think it's that bad
actually
also this move friends made into and if
yeah so if takes I can it's a few
options like I play Queen h4 or I could
take back just a matter of which which
wins the quickest probably takes here
and then each five like takes takes rook
chief 3 H 5 H 4 taking advantage of the
pinned that's a decent try
interesting
I've tooth defended unfortunately okay
so try and win like this
mmm this could be a nice finish
that was a nice finish okay
thanks for for the the message jacques
CEO over watch in watching your content
for a few months now it's helped me
improve a lot of chests started in
November I've been studying a lot and
now rated over two thousand nice keep it
up
how does a rule of a-square worth um if
you don't know what that refers to
I'm assuming maybe the end game like
king when the King tries to catch up on
oh I'm playing the same opponent I'll
play it for this time
I need to get revenge against this
opponent great content
oh thanks so much chow down I appreciate
that oh yeah there's probably some
Carlsen video discussing end games
that's about the square idea the square
has three sides of length wait what
three science or four sides not sure
play for
so I'm preventing b5 and in general I
just want like some some sort of grand
priests of it oh except the middle one
ah it's been so long since I've taken a
geometry class
yeah d5 is law as a playable move
they'll taking this move
without the inclusion of a 6 & a 4
there's some cool line takes takes takes
takes and then queen h5 but it didn't
work there's a reason why it didn't work
I think I actually talked about this in
my my Knight c3 st. Louis lecture
alright so I'll try and play
positionally this pawn is a bit weak ooh
now this pawns weak well I am I am up
upon and black can't attack this
immediately
maybe this move double D pawns are
actually not so bad because once I get
the pawn to g3 they'll control space
they're both defended this is an
isolated pawn which is constantly
attacked by the bishop g3 there's no
outpost square here
the bishop wants to be on e5 like the
previous game against this opponent at
slightly different circumstances oh
that's a good move
that probably winds up on back its lusts
unless I play this move
counter-attacking
oh but this would counter counter-attack
okay now I have visibly five so pawns
are defended I mean I'm kind of asking
to get pinned but that's okay
if Bishop d6 it's still defended
calculating f4 takes takes takes I
probably want to start with keen each
one and that way it prepares f4 and
doesn't allow the potential of Queen g4
interesting is this a free pawn the
previous game against this opponent I
was given so many free pawns social
Isilon e I so Lonnie usually refers to
isolated pawns which is no longer the
case for me Hans have become on isolated
oh that's a good move
do I bow test gambit take stakes t7
probably not I can't play a four here I
could play e6 maybe mmm it's complicated
there's also d4e fur is also interesting
actually it's a long variation I think I
think I should be up upon and then cuz
after it takes routine one oh no no ah I
was a mouse it I'm just losing a piece
now unless I'm not because takes takes
and I have a back rent matric ooh
accidental Nelson is leading to a point
being confused because yeah it takes
takes takes I'm eight
oh that's so lucky yeah I was
calculating rook t1 wow this is working
out beautifully lot can't take because
takes takes meets and now oh look at
this move Oh Tess Cabot's and and meets
all the great finish York c1 was
probably probably not objectively good
it was very confusing okay
thanks for subbing Monique something
something okay staffer can have the time
let's go Brian thanks for the bits so I
forgot accepted ooh
so Knight c3 okay it should be choose
the best move when it knows what to do
play this move
so if takes takes limb-threatening this
analyst free bishop opponents saw this
but didn't see this he's resigned yes
okay
whoa I'm catching up where am I oh I'm
top 10 let's go okay
neither that quick win I'm still not
going to finish in first but maybe maybe
top five oh think you Ryu for the bits
can you turn up oh yeah I'll do that
after this thing
let's go let's go yeah play some ear
thanks for the bits oh nice move lol
okay let's play some nice moves same
opening maybe yes
same opening Stafford you have a time
same exact line is okay this is slightly
different but still still a fun line to
play opening to learn as a beginner
something classical I mean me money for
or London opening for white as black you
can play me my Nike 45 I'm scanning is
simple to learn Sicilian in French do I
take I think I want to keep my Knights
we actually kind of have a positional
endgame and thanks like Samir so the
idea is neck c4 I don't know if it
doesn't much like c14 c1
maybe Knightly 3 it's a tricky move I
can't quite take that play to h6 if I
were a g5 then I take and play rogue h2
always great to watch Eric thank you
TW what does TW stand for something
water weight what does this move play b6
just killing the dreams of the night
play this difficult depending upon so I
can win this pawn for free opponent
doesn't see it for a special cause
someday someday I'm gonna try and stick
with like openings that win quickly g5
nice move oh this is a nice move to
attacking the king and threatening a
fork so keen e2 then I played this move
oh it doesn't fully work ooh I got too
excited
it doesn't fully work maybe this move I
have a couple pawns hanging but White
has a pond hanging - I can only take one
pawn
we can also defend alright so I'll take
this thing and now this Fonz attacked
ninety-four will be a very nice square
for the night
oh but white also can't easily defend
this maybe b5 the v5 takes takes in then
94 I guess there's a three okay so now
this pause attacked it was nice so I
took here attacking this I took here now
attacking this oh now take this
well they're the odds White's gonna get
forked if here then here if here then
here if here then here okay now I'm just
going for meat that's am a threat good
move
I'm still going for some kind of thing
like check here and then take some
nights with reading meat still had to
defend the pawn first I think this is
unstoppable
yes sir is King e6 but okay so I want
another game 5-5 is a goal oh I'm in
sixth place there's time for like one
more game probably maybe two more games
I don't know we'll see just have to play
quickly oh I'm playing oh this person
wasn't first earlier let's play Bishop
c4 I've been playing quickly translate
quickly back White's going for the win
White's going fair like a quick game
which is good which is what I want play
at five this move kept the pawn oh
that's very bold hmm play this move I'm
just going for like the the king size
attack probably probably the jeep on
push
hmm yeah cuz once once I push the Jeep
on oh that's a good move though I'll
play Queen Queen each fight doesn't make
sense
I don't like winning tribe eventually
the queen g2 all ideas to unleash this
pawn I shall play Queen G between g3
just develop I might have to play in the
center for a little bit
still trying to prepare this move blocks
putting up a decent defense but the
positions still really Pleasant it could
just take a long time to win mmm okay
that's what I like to see
yeah this is gonna be very hard for a
fact to defend because the combination
of the bishop the rook the queen coming
into h5 so I have a g6 here it spawns
defended I'll take what the pawn I don't
need to take the rook I think I'll just
um I'll torture Glock for a little bit
you can even do this if Ricky's seven or
g7 I think I can just take yeah there we
go
okay maybe time for one more game
hey there play oh oh if I win the next
game I can leapfrog oh it could be close
I'm not expecting to to jump so high in
the standings first place it looks like
it was losing - let's pick you for Oh
Smith more time don't think that's a
great move
maybe it's playable
Oh what's the line here Queen b3 okay
there we go
winning a queen no mercy no flagging 3mn
to go let's go let's go if I may in
first place
oh I need one more game because this
person also got points yeah it's not
guaranteed that the next game will count
for the standings but and now I'm really
kicking myself for losing that one one
game but who knows what what could have
happened
okay waiting for next game so this
person also playing I just have to go
like all out like aggressive opening og3
let's play h5 okay just trying to win as
quickly as humanly possible I'll play
Queen f6 okay it starts late d5
good move so I provoke see three weights
a bit stuck here now the Kings tied down
to the vision I'm printing oh that's a
queen trap almost is it b5 it's very
close to a queen trap okay so opponents
act the Queen 90 seconds left less than
90 seconds left just trying to meet
let's go first place
parents closed okay so it all comes down
to this person
thanks for the bits wait so this this
person is in second place no one else
can catch up so there's less than 50
seconds oh well this could be very close
I don't know let's not celebrate yet
well it just has to survive Chardin
thanks for the bits yeah that last game
just had to be hyper-aggressive miles
the cosmic thank you right
okay ten seconds what's gonna happen
something's happening or nothing's
happening
whites just stalling confetti confetti
let's go
I was not expected thank you thank you
Oh talkie-talkie mrs. whole thing I'll
probably have to put this on YouTube so
Tyga can rewatch um thanks everyone
I appreciate it thank you yeah special
thanks to to David Pakman for organizing
just a huge turnout 730 players how do
you finish because name is pac-man yeah
here we go
oh he finished 153 not bad did John
David Oh Destin so Omni so Omni destiny
is a is also a twitch streamer maybe
half a million followers that finished
finished ahead of David but yeah that
was fun
I played some especially towards the end
played some really like hyper aggressive
and gambits oh thanks the goat I'll take
that as a compliment was there a prize
pool I just played for fun I think this
was pretty sure this was just a
tournament for pretty fun and and yeah
just to have some escape from the
outside world so this guy has a name
thanks for subbing anyway yeah oh I'll
put this on YouTube thanks you two
people for watching and stay tuned for
more videos